oh hey how's it going bros my name is
epic Abbas today we're going to
Photoshop brilliant YouTube idea number
one request Photoshop a proper view to
subscriber ratio on to your vid roasted
oh yeah max well guess what you're not
bailed anymore
what are you gonna do about that you
think twice about roasting me okay
alright let's just let's just take this
video and let's just add a zero boom
[ __ ] that's still not enough it's kind
of sad not even a tenth not even a
[ __ ] pen not even one person who are
you listen this happens to everyone on
YouTube don't be mean alright
can you Photoshop some meaning in my
life thanks don't know don't make that
face
I recently discovered this new thing I
did it in one thumbnail and it's [ __ ]
amazing
okay Photoshop school if you want to do
it loosely knit just add a feather to
your black okay how specific should I be
press [ __ ] L on your keyboard on
feather type 25 or 15 or anything on
funky make a [ __ ] circle around your
pervy face hit ctrl J hit V drag that
[ __ ] over to your eye
alright ctrl J that [ __ ] again clean up
with eraser tool then what you want to
do is you want to take their eyes
duplicate them and put them on sky
William's father fighter of Justice is
that really meaning to life though I
don't know guess not next suggestion
haha can we put marina in Peru right now
we've successfully cropped Marina Joyce
out of this photo we can successfully
place her anywhere in the world that we
like Peru we we can put her next to that
a llama it's not even funny what what is
that much
hey it's marina Joy's in Peru everybody
everybody say Marina marina your entire
room now pair room no your dreams came
true Marie knew Mary knew you're in Peru
marina why just have one when you can
have to marry new Marina marina O'Mara
new Oh Mary no they're all in Peru
they're all in Peru with a llama or a
PACU baby oh my god what guys I'm in
Peru boy working
I can't I will not take a [ __ ] sofa
with you my experience is really not
even looking at the llama with sorry I
hate to superimpose this sort of thing
on people because you know it makes them
look a little betting thing but marina
you're a marina you're a marina oh ma
mama Rina that [ __ ] christ sorry
about that one marina if you're watching
love you so knowing how I ride I
wouldn't even mean for that yeah oh my
god is that a llama hitting on me
oh my kind of oh my god I can't believe
that llama look Oh No
make my son taller this is a you know
pretty intense hardcore Photoshop move
here oh wow wow it sure did the trick
goodnight [ __ ] is wrong with your cat
make my cat look normal
we should just need to look at that you
honestly in comparison I think that
looks pretty normal
make me pretty you know everyone is
beautiful on the inside
have you ever thought about how [ __ ]
weird a nose looked like well now you
have Jesus you're looking very good
there you're welcome
you're welcome and you add hair on me
please alright Jay I will grant your
wish
okay let's just give him here I don't
know I don't know my damn dog you
looking fun honestly doesn't look bad we
could definitely pull this look off and
I don't think a lot of a lot of people
can actually make them look more
intelligent somehow didn't think that
was possible
yeah
I see less of its face now so that
actually helps alright I'm going to
finish this video tomorrow
okay I'm back this is the first and well
let's check out some more common
Photoshop Shaun kicking the [ __ ] out of
you while Mark is punching the [ __ ] out
of you
god dammit okay this will probably take
a while but I'll do it for science
[ __ ] this is boring Jesus Christ why do
I even make this video
Wow that looks so real
oh my god you did such a good job Felix
they pull your eyelids to the ceiling
then jump off a chair the [ __ ] is wrong
with you make him happier please I don't
know it looks pretty I but I mean I I
mean simple simple liquefiable damn look
at that look how happy is there it is
now that's the smile this is what my
amazing talent is wasted doing [ __ ] you
make her look more beautiful she is
already extremely attractive and someone
I would definitely put my dick in
although the makeup not the best let's
give her a little bit better lipstick
clearly she doesn't have an upper lip
for some reason hashtag no no lips
got him so we're just gonna give give
her one transplanted from her bottom one
honestly doesn't look terrible
I would definitely let her suck my dick
[ __ ] yeah
yeah needs a little bit of a you know
eyeshadow beauty is all in the
subtleties let's give her a little bit
more of that cleavage damn yes
[Music]
hell yeah [ __ ] yeah now let's try and
make the face a little less hideous
seems to be a bit of a challenge get rid
of the horrible teenage acne I'm working
on a little bit of an erection here I'm
not gonna lie there we go beautiful
stunning you know barely any Photoshop
involved and I would definitely you know
oh look at Dan with the green screen
huh so like I can make some weird
artwork out of this
[Music]
what is happening all right I don't know
what am I doing here it's just fun to
watch I don't think so and that's the
last one that came up on the lick Wow
haven't we learned a lot here today
pleasure to have you along partner and
as always leave a like I forget to ask
for likes
would you would you mind we too much to
ask you tell me please come on just
anyway check out another video where I
Photoshop as well if you enjoyed this
one I think you'll like it as well check
it out and as always head
[Music]